hi today uh
i'd like to talk about uh
meditation and the and what we do in
aikido
and why perhaps in the old
days ninety percent of the aikidoka when
i was training
is not interested at all i don't know
about the modern
aikidoka but most of your switch off
once i start talking
so i'm going to keep this
video very short
this i was reading an article on
facebook about nishio
scentsy and how repeatedly these
uh old masters as brilliant as they were
they used to say that nobody understood
her scentsy
it was as if he was talking to the gods
and
he never made sense to them so he didn't
understand it
and they just copied his aikido
this appears to be what the world has
done that's what i've done
and i've put today in this shop
this bunch of flowers behind me
and i'd like to make a point about
you focusing on the flowers now you
might not be interested in flowers
but the variety of flowers
makes it interesting
yes you could have just one species of
flower
and that would also be very nice to look
at
but to me in my first stages
aikido was so exciting that i'd be happy
with
one let's say a rose rose in there
somewhere
pink one
and this keeps us going
the amazing thing about aikido is it has
all these facets that
really just inspire us and they keep
pushing buttons
but we we don't seem to be interested in
looking at the deeper
deeper part of the art the thing about
you know oh scentsy nobody could
understand him
i have followed quite a lot of teachers
i don't normally mention names
but when i was in america in the mid-80s
i went to a seminar and there was
several teachers frank duran
uh bob nadeau
bruce clicksteen juan nuins
kayla fader pat hendricks
all these great senses and i should be
saying sensei hendricks sensei
knowings and that okay so please forgive
me for that part
but uh you know when you are in that era
they become your friends and you just
call them by name except for on the map
or if you're with students
you always use the word sensei
as i'm sure you know
right so i'm going to make a much
much detailed and longer film
on my patreon site because i think
us older aikidoka
especially the westerners we've got a
lot of knowledge we've watched the
japanese
we've been taught by the japanese but
they don't tell you a lot
of depth about how how they actually
think
what they're like as human beings you
know what if we just
absorb their eye keto techniques and
either want to be like them or
take something away that they've got on
offer
but i'm an individual the same as you
are listening to me
and i want you to learn about like the
flowers here
i don't want you to learn about flowers
i want you to learn about
there's far more that makes us
the human being work and therefore
kochie toei he said aikido in daily life
now you don't go along the road using
techniques on everybody you
come to meet but
by enjoying aikido as you get older
you perhaps become a better person you
might start helping people
you might start looking towards how you
can better
the life of others you might start
enjoying
flowers gardening you might start doing
art
photography your hobbies may expand to
other things outside of
just not just you know as gucci and
aggie
a good ken car good job ski a good
carter so
i've decided that i want to give my
depth of knowledge but more about
think i'm a very traditional aikidoka as
most of you would know
and i believe in the strong technical
form
that will work as a martial art and it
will work on the street
if you have to use it i also want to
talk about our
telepathic abilities the depth of a
the psychic mind um
you don't have to believe in god or the
afterlife
but we we have two sides to us
we don't like to often look at the other
side
i don't know why and we find or tell us
something we don't want to
hear perhaps it will
but i want to go into the meditative
depths and i've
what i've done different um i might have
said on another video
what i've done different is i've watched
these teachers who throw
without touching we saw a scentsy doing
it
on lots of films as he got older
a lot of people said oh the uk has
respected him and
they just fell down for him well what
i've done
is i looked at that and i thought with
my own intelligent mind
pat said true perhaps i respected him he
was old
perhaps he couldn't do it but they
wanted to make him still
look good respect him
and then the the more modern teachers
i know in the hong kong dojo there's a
teacher
he throws people without touching
so what i done was i tried in different
dojos around the world
how i could pick somebody and try it
and it worked every time on them it
won't work in an maa
spring and it won't work um you know
doing
crab brazilian jiu-jitsu and that
but what it will do is it will work on
the titanic
but you have to focus your mind and
telepathically
plug in you look around the class you
never met any of them before but you
look around the class all of a sudden
something in your mind
tells you that person will be
responsible
to your mind power if you haven't
switched off already and think that i
need to see a mind doctor
bear with me once you
once you connect that there's something
i'll tell you but
your your inner inner self and your
outer self even though you are together
fears will it work will i look a fall if
i try
it in time you'll overcome that
and again as i say my patreon site i'm
going to go into detailed depth
of how you can test it how you can
practice it
how you can build it up doesn't have to
be daily
weekly monthly yearly you do it when you
want
but you start learning how to control
another's
mind but again only think that it will
work on the tatami
where there's other like-minded people
it won't work on them all
if you're a positive and a negative and
you know that
that will work then you can make it work
and you'll know this okay
most of you as i say 90 of the people
i've ever met on the map
don't want to know about it they think
you're weirdo
but i'm gonna teach you my knowledge of
many many years of how i've been doing
it
i don't do it that often because
most people even in the students if
there's a hundred students
lined up in front of you perhaps only
10 of those hundred or less
will think that it's actually working
they won't know how it's
being done but they think it's like some
magic trick
it's not and you can do it but what it
does is
it teaches you how to be more aware how
to have better zan shin
you know we we've all got the same minds
we're all
you know working it out the same anyway
thanks for your time and um if you
look below you can find the link to my
patreon page
and if you want to subscribe to the the
minimum amount please do so you can
always
unsubscribe it's not a thing that you've
got
look up forever and let's see how we go
thanks for your time